it's one of the most challenging jobs in
the country managing argentina's economy
in times of trouble
on monday sylvina batakis was sworn in
as economy minister by president alberto
fernandez see huro promising to
jump-start argentina's economy
we are convinced argentina's direction
has to do with our fiscal management
following the president's economic
program and of course boosting
argentina's exports and re-evaluating
our currency which is achieved with more
reserves
but doing so won't be easy batakis is
replacing martin goman who resigned on
saturday he was in charge of the tough
negotiations of over 40 billion dollars
with the international monetary fund
even though the negotiations proved
successful guzman was constantly
attacked by the powerful former
president and now vice president
christina fernandez the kirchner who did
not agree with the handling of the
economy
argentina is struggling with very high
insulation around five percent a month
high poverty and exchange rate controls
that have a huge impact in the economy a
change in the ministry of economy
generates lots of uncertainty in a
country like argentina and that
uncertainty increases the price of the
us dollar on the streets and that in
most cases means more inflation
argentines are used to living in crisis
they have survived one every other
decade
people on the streets are watching the
latest developments very carefully
obviously there is a lot of uncertainty
we don't know which direction we are
going right or left whichever but what
argentines need is a direction and sadly
we don't have one
tensions have been running high between
president alberto fernandez and
christina kirchner for months
pataki's appointment is seen as a win
for the far left-leaning faction in
government who are close to the vice
president and critical of the agreement
with the imf
populism needs money to calm the people
down and there is no money they have no
money to give away and whatever they
will give they will have to print and
that will increase inflation even more
we have a huge problem i don't see a way
to make it work
[Music]
but has a difficult task ahead she has
to fight inflation generate jobs and
increase the country's reserves without
displeasing argentina's vice president
who for many has now more power than the
president himself
al jazeera buenos aires